how much freedom do people have to if
you like to choose their identities and
to what extent they chosen for them and
actually the answer
it's a it's a curious mix of both that
in there are some identities that we we
kind of choose that we you know the sort
of stereotypical example might be we
choose our friends we don't choose our
family well that's obviously kind of
true in some sense but nevertheless we
in both cases actually it's but neither
is entirely true we sum to a certain
extent your friends are chosen as a
function of the kinds of plot you know
where you enter school and where you
live so actually you're much more likely
to have your friends from some of you
live next door to and we don't actually
choose friends from the other side of
town or other countries or maybe other
social classes and things like that and
by the same token even within our
families well we actually make wee-wee
if you like make choices about which
parts the family we want to spend time
with and we probably spend time with
those bits of the family that make us
feel better and that we feel better
being a part of so if you like in all
instances there's a kind of a mix of
choice and it being prescribed in some
sense but actually that's really
critical the sense that we feel that
their voice it upon us actually has a
big impact we we identify less with
groups where we feel we haven't had a
choice in being part of them but and in
many ways we work hard to imagine or to
construe situations in which we feel we
have choice but there are plenty of
situations in which we have no choice
whatsoever and that has very particular
consequences that we tryna in terms of
behavior that our research tries to
unpack and make sense of